today I'm going to be talking about an
interesting ICO project which is
scheduled to launch its main sale on
June 3rd it's called share ring and
sharing calls itself the world's first
trusted token for sharing services and
it plans to offer one way to pay for
sharing everything no matter what it is
and importantly no matter where you are
so let's discuss some of the problems
that share ring wants to solve first of
all most people are aware of only the
major sharing economies like uber Airbnb
but there are thousands out there and
right now providers are pretty heavily
segmented or they operate only within
very small local markets again other
than these major players that everybody
is familiar with and signing up for
these sharing economy companies is
really a pretty big hassle right each
one has a different method to sign up
and identify oneself to gain access to
the platform and the assets on that
platform the ways in which you make sure
that you got the shared asset when where
and in the form you want can be
uncertain and sometimes it's pretty
complicated and if you're traveling and
you want to use one of these platforms
many providers will only allow access to
local residents or they'll charge
international travelers in their local
currency which can create frustration
because of their bureaucracies and the
sort of costs that are involved with
this and then obviously there's also a
trust issue right how do you know that
the company or individual provider is
ethical and legitimate what recourse do
you have if something goes wrong what
about the database is the database
secure is your privacy protected will it
still be around tomorrow and Trust is
sort of a fundamental importance when it
comes to sharing assets that belong to
third parties or services offered by
such third parties so the idea with
sharing is to put trust back in the
system and the idea is actually one
token ecosystem right so the idea of
sharing is
you can use share ledger to rent cars or
trucks or trailers maybe even heavy
equipment share ledger can be used to
facilitate booking and payment for
delivery drivers or garden sharing
peer-to-peer lending a food bank social
dining travel and real estate related
stuff even assets right like book
swapping clothes swapping fractional
ownership of assets and then I mentioned
Airbnb and uber transportation also
write car sharing ride-sharing and car
pooling so a few elements of the sharing
project number one they want quick and
easy sharing transaction validation as
well as immutable records of the data
that's sort of a key blockchain thing
the ability to add more attributes to an
account like ID confirmation or
someone's rental history or asset
ownership things like that there are a
couple tokens there's the share pay
token shrp which is used by customers to
pay for the rental of assets and then
you've got the share token SHR which the
providers use to pay for their access to
the share ledger blockchain and that
includes adding assets to it renting out
assets adding attributes adding smart
contracts and lots of other features and
then a provider can earn share pay by
renting out their asset like a car for
example and then they can use the tokens
to for example rent an apartment
thanks to this multi industry sort of
cross industry application and then as
is the case with a number of block
chains you can also earn tokens by
hosting a node and there can be custom
rules added to assets or wallets to
allow for a number of different sharing
scenarios the team is a very interesting
and diverse team Tim boss is the CEO
we've spoken to Tim and his background
is pretty well known to us Rowan LePage
is the CEO Oh
from a sort of more straight ahead
business analysis background Neville
Christie is the investment director and
you know I've talked before about how
as great as a project can be in terms of
the idea if you're running an ICO you
need someone who knows how to run
investment projects right and that
that's something that is not always
there for some of these projects Peter
David is the non-executive director he
has an experienced lifetime of
experience in the tech business world
and then Jayne Sadler kid
another non-executive director pretty
diverse group of people from a number of
different areas of business token sale
allocation 60% of the tokens are going
to the contributors there's going to be
a 1% airdrop and a 5% bounty program and
then 10% of the tokens will be
distributed to advisers 24 percent will
be kept by sharing so not an altogether
unusual allocation and the as sharing
has made clear the sharing Treasury
itself will be publicly auditable and
the public address of the cryptocurrency
wallets is going to be published on the
share ring website allocation of tokens
after the ICO is going to be roughly as
follows although they are going to
present the full budget during the
mainsail 30% for the main net
development 10% for external reviews and
tech validation by third parties 30% for
incubators and bonuses to get working on
third-party product integrations and
that I mean if you think about make or
break here right it's buying it's our
people seeing the value and are they
going to use this and incubating the
third product integrations it's not like
a nice-to-have it's an absolute and
total necessity 20% for global marketing
and promotions and then 10% for
contingency funds they will lock up
unsold tokens pre token sharing event
February 2018 the pre TSE ends May 2018
and then the TSE period until June 4th
2018 which is where we are now
a number of different contribution tiers
which you can read about don't have to
go through that in detail now so big
picture we've talked a lot about the
fragmentation that exists in the crypto
world number one this specifically is an
ICO that's looking at fragmentation
within the sharing economy so the idea
is fantastic the challenge is you need
the buy-in right you need to have enough
industry participants so that someone
would say okay I can get housing rent a
car as well as other services for my
trip all through the sharing system such
that it's obviously more convenient to
do that than to use Airbnb for one thing
and then uber for something else
etc etc the number one factor assuming
of course that the technology is in
place and I think the technology is
actually it's ambitious but they have
the team to do the technology part it's
going to be all about buy-in and that's
why I want to see as much focus as
possible being put on bringing in those
third party partners because that's
ultimately what it's going to come down
to nothing in this review is meant to be
considered investment advice everybody
should do their own research if they're
going to make any financial decision
it's a review of the project and my
thoughts on the possibility of the
project success and you can read more
about the sharing ICO and project by
looking at the links in the video
description below